overwatch halloween update is is live
now kind of a surprise drop that had all
of us it includes some loot boxes it
includes some single-player content and
our resident Blizzard expert Erik Tay
got a chance to sit down and play some
of and he's going to be joined by
Marrakech Eric so you went through the
the knew you wouldn't call it's a brawl
it's a brawl so yeah in its it's single
player it's definitely different than
any of the other well not a single
player necessarily school its co-op
against in the AI and it's not your
traditional AI in the sense that you're
fighting other heroes it's more of like
a like I think as Joe and some of the
chat people I mentioned earlier it's
like man vs the machines in tf2 where
it's you and three other people playing
online together against like a horde of
robots as well as you know there's a
reaper there's a road hog and a mercy
and junk rat that you have to deal with
all the same time your garden tools
halloween costumes on yes exactly
halloween theme i think is really cool
um it's not like super like in-depth but
it's definitely fun for the first time
and like the hard mode was really hard
like Joey tried twice and we failed
twice mr. SRAM subs from easy to hard as
it ja it's more more and harder and like
I make sense yeah pretty much your
standard you know difficulty kind of
tier things so um how would you compare
it to the tf2 horde mode because that I
found actually pretty scaled pretty
difficult in terms of if you you know it
it didn't get that much easier if you
didn't have a full stack of people
playing so if you only had like three or
four you were like struggling pretty
heavy it's all these different bots
coming at you yeah I mean hard was
definitely like leaps and bounds harder
than normal which is not always the case
but he did normal like the regular mode
the first time and he succeeded kind of
no problem they died a little bit but in
hard they because of the lack
communication yeah they died relatively
quickly like the first like big wave
where Reaper shows up they he pretty
much died both times there was there's
probably like three tiers if you don't
get to choose your characters it's not
like you can have a party with like a
mercy yeah
you you have a set your only healer is
going to be Anna you have enough solder
76 who are the other two McCree and Hans
oh so they tailor-made who you could
pick on purpose because obviously having
like a bash in would be Opie because you
could just stay in a lane or near the
door and just hose things down so they
must have went through some type of
tests and said oh these four are pretty
balanced for this mode and there's
enough skills and abilities for you to
deal with the situation properly and
whatnot on it was fun I it's it's the
first time there's something like this
in overwatch Lucille Ball's of dabble in
kind of like a rocket League type you
know fun fun kind of mode but this is
the first time you kind of got to like
join together and like you know fight
like against the Horde and stuff like
that I'm interested to see if they do
anything more extensive down the road
because I think that's really cool to
have something like a PVE type of
content in this very PvP heavy game and
I think so far the events have been
pretty good though like they've been
solid you can also argue their kind of
money grabs but hey you don't have to
you don't have to buy any of the skins
or any of the emotes and stuff that you
see but well you are you more likely to
get drops I know when they did their
previous skins for the Olympics I was
just naturally getting pretty some
pretty sweet Olympic drops for skins and
some victory poses yeah so like every
time you level you will get a Halloween
loop box which is like going to run for
about a month I think that event ends on
the first of November you can also buy
some of the skins if you had
pre-existing like coins or gold it's
just three times the amount which is
kind of insane but hey if you had gold
stored up at least you can buy them um
you also get one free one I think just
for you know playing so there's that but
would you lizard does for almost all of
their games like if you log in for an
event you're gonna get something that
that little little taste just a little
taste you know but just enough to make
you want to drop some hot cash you can
we drop some hot cash on streams how
much money did you say we dropped forty
dollars which is the equivalent of 50
boxes which is good I mean it depends on
how you look I mean luckily Joey got
what he wanted which was
don't cry drunk rat which is like um
like the the mad scientist version it's
so perfect for John crap by the way like
some of these skins are perfect I like
want to get into them in a little bit
though that murse the mercy yeah yeah
but the skins are great but you could
argue that dropping forty dollars is
equivalent to like almost buying a game
right so after you've bought it yeah
exactly so how much money did you get
cuz like I find that to be the more
valid where the coins the in-game coins
because it's like that's where you get
to choose what you want whereas in the
boxes you're always taking the gamble
that you're hoping you're going to get
what you want but if you can drop like a
thousand then at least you're going to
get the skin that you want it anyway
unfortunately there's no surefire way of
getting coins though so like you just
have to gamble on the boxes and either
get dupes or gold gold boxes within the
boxes so it's their way of getting
people to buy boxes essentially but
again like I will say it's not like a
pay to win thing it hasn't been it's a
pay to look good thing so you can pay to
look good if you want to obviously you
can still earn them it's just a lot
slower and you have to be really lucky
like I'm sure there's some people that
open their first box and got a legendary
and then there's also some people that
open their box and got a blue and was
like oh great i got a blue you know it's
okay or y'all probably plenty of dupes
um well yeah i think it is what it is i
think it's just like this isn't the
first time activision has like
Activision Blizzard they're kind of the
same you know in a way done this because
they do it for destiny destiny will have
a halloween event in which case you can
buy stuff so you know hey to each their
own i think it's a little bit more fun
with the way the blizzard does it
because it's completely out of the it's
not in reality it's not set in the
game's reality like this is just kind of
a weird silly side thing so it's gonna
be it's very halloween themed and for me
compared to the olympics i think it's
much more fun and exciting Oh
definitions are so much cooler you look
at like in the Olympics you got a little
bit more into their lore like what what
country is what nationality is all these
characters were fun from but you kind of
already knew but it's still nice to see
them it was nice to see tracer like in
her she was a runner would that made
sense for her character and you know she
had looked great britain on it and so
that was like a nice piece of her Laura
but you look at like the Halloween box
and you get to be way
more creative with these characters and
you give a character like mercy
something that she's needed since the
beginning like I can't I would never
wanted any of mercy skins I play a lot
of mercy I never wanted the devil
costume I just wasn't into it I didn't
like any of her skins that witch costume
is perfect is the perfect fit for her
attitude in her character she's like a
fun cheeky character she's like she's
like really positive and a bit flirty
like it's just like that which is just
spot-on for her and it's it's perfect
within the lure of all these characters
that they would dress up for Halloween
or they would have these alternate
personas so like how fun is it to like
watch this mercy skin and like wanna
play as her I would drop so much money
just to have that mercy which that's
what they want to hear I know and then I
I do like that you don't have to drop
money is the ridiculous number of points
but you can spend your end game points
to get these as well would you couldn't
do from the Olympics yeah God do you
learn they learned a little bit sprays
hey hey you gotta are in Orangi feck oh
yeah that's how they get you you know
Bray's suck but there was so many other
good ones like um soldiers such an
iconic one to not only is it like a
zombie but it's the Michael Jackson
zombie like he's got the same like red
jacket and pants he's got like thriller
elements to him i guess it's rad like
you can't argue with that like it's
really well done so are you gonna try to
drop money are you just really aiming
for that mercy skin just gonna work
everything towards I want the mercy scan
there's a few others that I also really
enjoyed I mean it's it's hard to like
not give nods to a few of these because
they are good i'd be willing to I don't
my association with skins and to money
is different than taze they're different
for all of us like the Symetra vampire
that's like ideal that one's really
really good and then there was like a
few that this wasn't even a skin but I
just thought this was really good
Winston has an emote where he makes a
shadow puppet with his little feeties is
so cute and I just absolutely wanted
I've spent hard coin on I did an emote
for zenyatta where he is
try and be all peaceful and then he like
makes a little spoon like a face at you
and like tries to antagonize people i
think it's rad that they made zenyatta
go against his character to be like
she's gonna mess with people mentales i
think that's really good that they're
doing that so to give Winston like this
he's like a scientist he's pretty
serious to give him this anecdotal funny
trait to him that he's he's like a
little bit of a comedian and he's he's
got this light-hearted a sense of
childlike wonder which is a part of his
character Laura is so good and I would
pay for that too so there's like three
or four pieces I even like this in yata
skulls I thought that was really rad to
he's got all these little skulls around
them i think you can see it right now I
think it's called Scully attitude which
not not shocking yeah yeah pretty good I
think all those are really rad I mean
they've they've hooked me when you start
asking for real money I mean that's
that's like always a tough one and it's
different for each person you know what
is forty dollars value today is
different to you as different to me but
I'd certainly will be playing more this
month no you to increase my odds of
getting that which skin so damn nuh
actually did that I just thought about
now that Mary kind of talked about like
playing more it's actually if you happen
to be like right on the cusp of
prestiging this is like the the best
time like this the min-max mentality in
my head because so basically when you
prestige right you start at one again
yeah but leveling from one to ten is
like super fast compared to like 40 to
50 60 to 70 so like if you're like there
by to prestige because you're probably
gonna get like ten boxes like easy peasy
did you get what you wanted I know you
got a little bit of a head sorry didn't
I I ultimately didn't get to play too
much this morning I was pretty much on
the stream with Joey and I told him hey
you've been playing more as like
frequently like more recently so I was
like hey might as well do it on your
account instead of mine so that you can
enjoy them because I've gotten to do the
last like what a new streams I got to
buy a hundred boxes during Olympics oh
I'm good on that you know but there are
some that I want I want Reaper really
bad you know sleepy hollow kind of like
the pumpkin head is like really cool his
his shotguns got the like candle wicks
on them
on one that skull mask on Anna yeah
there's a few really that one's not bad
but Anna for the Frankenstein row dogs
like really good so road hog has a new
weapon as well like they've colored his
weapon so some of them like even their
items are like just they've made really
cool so detailed they're really nice and
it's cool for a blizzard i think i think
it's like not just for them monetarily
but for like their art team and stuff
like that for them to be able to like
kind of stretch their creative juices
during these periods i think it's
probably a lot of fun for them so yeah
so it's a lot of really exciting
halloween content coming out of
overwatch i know i'm probably going to
spend a little bit more time in the game
to make sure i can also get that mercy
skin because it's really cool and will
probably learn a lot more about what
blizzard has in store for overwatch at
blizzcon later this year which later
this month which you can stay tuned to
gamespot to learn all about